[Music]
good afternoon everybody um uh let's
Jump Right In with a question how many
raise your hand if you're part of a
parallel society
today all right maybe 5 to 10% of the
room uh how many of you unsure raise
your hand if you're unsure
maybe okay how many of you actively want
to like this is something like yes I'm
ready for a parallel society and I want
to be a part of one I just don't know
yet raise your hand all right so like
about a third a third a third so um uh
before we dive in I think um I kind of
want to start the framing of this
conversation because to least in my view
that we're already live actors in
parallel societies today right um if
you're in a memec coin cult you're
leveraging crypto networks for most of
your Finance uh in a favorite Discord or
telegram group um those s constitute um
you know very uh parallel structures um
that Downstream of that I mean what's
crypto at a $2.5 trillion doll market
cap Downstream of those those Capital
allocation those conversations uh really
already do have quite a bit of impact um
into the world today the environment
today so I kind of want us to be in that
framing uh so with that in mind um and
my name is Angelo founder of build
cities uh we're a platform for for
economic development and what we've
basically done to do that is create
digital Twins or city Dows of cities
around the world um that can
permissionless um um uh do Capital
formation uh help people find their kind
of digital tribes in their local areas
uh and we actually we actively work with
municipalities uh around the world to
also help them achieve some of their
Economic Development goals uh and um
with that I'm also joined by Will Wang
rsid
uh if you haven't if you don't have a
plow ID I'm was going to pull mine out
here fell out but they're very cool plow
ID all that will give a quick intro and
um overview of the of the
project thanks Angelo so um how many of
you know what Pala
means wow one yeah it's about the right
statistics like about less than
10% even know about you know what Pala
is
uh is actually the world third smallest
country and it has a population of less
than 20,000
people uh it's physically located like
four hours flight from here so you can
reach it from
Manila Hong Kong or
taipe and we're a very young country
born in 1994 before before that it was
you know owned by us and they took from
the Japanese you know from the World War
II and before that Japanese took it from
Germany and then before that German took
it from Spain so we re recent
independent
country so The Residency program that we
offer uh which is the RNs ID program is
a reference to the e
e residency if you guys have heard about
Estonia e
residency and we are the second country
offering this program uh that allows you
to uh I think Angelo shows you guys but
it you know I brought a sample over here
it look like
this so it means you can have a legally
recognized ID from another jurisdiction
other than your current one right so a
lot of countries have certain I mean
limitations to your identity right some
of the country IDs they cannot open like
US dollar bank accounts and some
countries you know like the crypto
exchanges they don't take they don't
take your ID because you know your
jurisdiction may not welcome or crypto
is illegal right and there's countries
like India you know each time you do a
crypto transaction there's 30% tax right
and you would have to kind of insert
your um other car all car number
something and then they track you if you
lose money you cannot you know like kind
of deduct your tax but if you win you
pay
30% so this is part of the division of
RNs right so a lot of people ask like
are you just like you know making ID or
something the the answer is no okay so
at RNs we have um a vision to solve two
very difficult problems right number one
is
restriction and number two is
overexposure so when I say restriction
right I already mentioned a few right
like you don't you know like certain
ideas like uh turkey ID right you cannot
open um open on uh interact intera
broker so you don't have access to US
Stocks some country you don't have
dollar access and what I say by
overexposure is each time you check into
a hotel you know you they have to make a
copy of your passport or your ID or or
something right everywhere you go and
then if you try to buy something then
you know online you have to insert your
physical address so we're trying to
figure out a way of you know like what
we call as minimum disclosure for
constraint
use right one of the examples would be
when you apply for a job right you have
to show them your your your resume and
on there you know they can see oh my
last name Wang this probably Asian and
the first name Jennifer that's probably
a female that is not necessary right the
only information that need to know is
about your expertise like where you
graduated or like your work experience
don't need to know whether you are a
female or male they don't need to know
your race right so that's what we call
minimum disclosure for constrain use I
just give one specific example for job
application there's a lot of others but
at RNs we solve those two
problems um so yeah when I when I um
first kind of started to learn about RNs
ID and and palow uh and the relationship
there it's really kind of the first
example I can think of where a country
is bridging into these Global and
potentially one day kind of um
interplanetary uh networks these crypto
networks right where you are registering
as I understand you need to you you do
register it with a onchain identifier
you know through metamask or whatnot the
same one that you might be using for buy
the latest mem coin or whatever so
there's all these kind of interesting
identifiers onchain identifiers from a
global populace base and it's almost
like this kind of digital net um so um
you kind of went over some of the
benefits for the end user what is what
is palao really kind of getting out of
this steal I imagine imagine several
things but all I should kind of you know
take that yeah yeah absolutely so uh the
the the the major industry for palao is
tourism so you know during covid the
country is very um yeah it's actually
pretty uh bad situation so the president
traveled to uh to Stanford where I was
visor at DTI at at that moment and we
were offering some advice right like how
can you boost your economy without
tourism and and the island only have
20,000 people right so you know we tell
him that like you need to get people
first right and Pala you know is not is
not like other Asian countries like
Singapore or Japan is not an immigrant
country they don't want a lot of people
to compact the island so what we tell
them is to to to to try to reference to
the Estonian model right you can sign up
people remotely right they don't even
need to be here they just need an
identity from your country and you have
already have a fre pretty like friendly
tax situation where you know if you
don't earn income from palao then
there's no tax so even you stay in a
country if your employer is in the US
and you are like aition Nomad you pay
zero tax I mean like other than if
you're a US citizen but there's still
there's 90,000 something if you uh don't
stay in us for um you know for I think
300 30 days you know if you're outside
of us you have those um threshold of uh
of of 90 something, that you don't need
to pay uh pay tax
for yeah so so sounds like can some
largely economic drivers for um for
palao which which makes a lot of sense
we we see this a lot at build cities I
mean you you don't even uh even outside
of our project you see these countries
and even cities within countries um
paying to have um in this case it's
usually Talent what we see a lot of so
right if you're in you know some of
these networks you know a lot of the
Technologies we're talking about here
they're very Frontier Technologies right
they're attracting some of the best and
brightest brains uh in the world and um
any kind of forward-looking
country uh really you know they want
they they they want to be able to to
leverage that right um and uh because
Downstream of that it it does end up you
know uh attracting more economic drivers
in this case there's a direct um
business model that's already working
and it's and it's really cool to see um
let's move over to kind of the um um you
know the theme of of of this conference
for parallel societies uh logo has just
done such an incredible job kind of um
surfacing this theme and there is you
know a lot of the tech that logos is
working on and a lot of people in crypto
in general is it's very very censorship
resistant very uh privacy preserving
right um you know we're all kind of uh I
think kind of gravitating towards this
ideals of a sovereign individual which
um I think a lot of us maybe in this
room can kind of operate under this
assumption that like that's can be
sometimes an authentical to a
government's initiatives right they they
might they want to know probably a lot
about you and um so how do you
reconcile the you know the sovereignty
of of an individual let's you can take
an extreme case like if if Satoshi
wanted to be an e resident but didn't
want to give his ID like how do you
reconcile those um obligations between
both parties between the the nation
state and kind of you know these these e
residents yeah that's actually a a very
good question so the approach that plow
take is kind of like um midle approach
right so what we offer you is not only
just a plastic ID right we also allow
you to Mint your ID on
ethereum and on there where we deploy a
method to only have open
claims instead of exact you your instead
of your exact birthday right we have
open claims of over 21 true over 18 true
cuz that's the only information
you need to show to external like if you
go to a bar they just need to prove
you're over 21 right and they just they
just need to look at those claims and
you know
jurisdiction um you know like your uh
your own uh
jurisdiction and so what we call is
nonp right uh nonpersonal identifiable
information right it can still to show
that you know like is there still like
open claims like sanction list sanction
check you know pass or pfp false like
those kind of sanctions requirement of
you know a lot of uh Financial instit uh
institutions that's why we called like
minimum disclosure for constraint use
right and what we deploy was also a
method for institutions to verify
whether you are a legal resident of our
country with zero knowledge
verification right so we use all the
leaves of your like birthday your your
name everything we calculate a mo rout
right and they without exchanging
information with a financial institution
or any institution who want to verify
they just need to compare to see oh is
that part of your program by comparing
the root and even plow government or us
we cannot change your information
because once we change that then your
roote changes so that that takes the
freedom of our our ability away right so
at the end of that you are the
controller of your own identity right
you have that roote and you have it
forever yeah I think um um so um
obviously there's a lot of uh even just
process right just over 18 under 18
right these are kind of simple questions
that don't need a technical layer to be
able to just Implement those kind of uh
wise processes and and um again I think
you know we we observe um uh you know
when things are designed right but but
again also back to back to this point
that's like hey you know there's this
there's this Brain Trust like we have
leverage right as you know call them
Network Societies or parallel Society
right there is leverage in those
communities that you can kind of bring
to the table I think when um you know
setting up these relationships with the
mun municipality or um you know
regulatory where it's like hey these are
these are non-negotiables right um and I
think it also there's so much
circumstantial pieces right there's
there's sometimes there's times to be
very collaborative uh there's definitely
times where you want to kind of um you
know circumvent or be is um um you know
really kind of start leaning forward
into into some of more of those um um
censorship resistent Technologies
depending on the you know really just
depending on the country and
jurisdiction um I want to shift over to
um thinking forward um both for
rnid and maybe the potential domino
effect into other countries that kind of
want to adopt this what are some of the
top you know number one two three
considerations for uh a country that
might want to implement a similar
program and uh on the same on the same
vein is there a criteria that benefit
better than others I know there's a lot
of um similar programs in smaller
islands in the Caribbean um you know uh
can you kind of give us maybe an
overview the the broader landscape and
um what country should be considering on
uh you know if they want to implement
their own programs yeah yeah so that
depends on your um your goal right if
you want to physically move there I
think kind of like number one uh
priority is still the infr infastructure
right how safe is the country and if
there are any like you know educational
or like work opportunities or if you are
a nomad still you need to have certain
level of of uh Assurance right of of the
uh how the uh the the cities can uh
Supply your your your basic need right
and then about like digital programs you
know we have palao we have
Estonia and then there's the good thing
about like you know you you you
mentioned about uh censorship is because
there's like it just there's 200
countries uh in the world right if one
country is not like trading you nice
like I mean other countries like
Thailand right offering like this NAD
Visa I think since the um June of this
year they actually attract a lot of uh a
lot of attention right so if your
country is not offering like what is
needed
from The Nomad Community then other
countries they will because there's 35
million if not if I'm not mistaken
digital Nomad in the world right and
these are like pretty well uh situated
people I mean half of them from us and
they earn you know pretty uh nice uh
salaries and this is a a great uh
driving economic driving force right
they come and then they need to to stay
in a hotel they need to like you know
like do service they go to restaurant
they are um but I understand this very
well because you know we depend on uh on
tourism so back to sorry back to your uh
the question about like other countries
like you know there's um definitely like
Thailand for the digal NORAD Visa
there's uh Philippines you know like uh
you spend
$75,000 for you need to buy their uh the
the stock from their uh from from their
country and if you're over like 50 years
sold you can spend like
20,000 and there's like you know country
offering uh passport programs you know
in the Caribbeans you have sanes you
have greenada these countries like um
lowest possible you get you know you
spend $100,000 to uh for donation and if
you uh spend over you know 200,000 or
250,000 to buy a property you know
you're probably eligible as well which
is similar to the gree and uh a lot of
the uh uh the Portugal programs um in
Europe those are like for you to really
consider to to to go and uh and live
there but if you're just looking for
like a legal ID for kic probably you
know we also offered just offered today
you know like uh for our fiveyear pal ID
holder and the longer we uh actually uh
sign them for their uh Thailand drivers
license right they're probably uh able
to get it on Friday so you have a tie
drivers license I I not in my pocket
soan now but uh you know the uh the tie
driver's license have two years of
validity right you can drive it you can
drive a car not only in Thailand but
also in Asian uh Asian Asian countries
like southeast Asia basically and you
can use it I tried to check in the
hotels this work perfect and you can use
it also as a secondary ID other than
your passport when you try to open a
bank account so there's really uh you
know many program
like you know for Singapore there's um
this EP program that you can just you
know find a company or pay your your
yourself like a a nice salary and then
uh pay 177% tax and in one year you can
apply for their PR right similar as
there's a the Japan one in one year you
can get the Japanese um uh green card
right but you you have to like kind of
uh uh put yourself under a certain
Japanese company of your friends or
yourself and in five years you can apply
for the uh Japanese passport which ranks
number two around the world being number
one being Singapore and and for uh for
Korea they used to have this
$250,000 U uh you program I think they
recently raise it to a million or
something but similar to like Japan or
Singapore if you get the uh the working
Visa there you know the normal Pace will
take you like five years to uh to get uh
their permanent res presidency and and
also you know passport programs so
really you know try to to to see which
options work for you because a lot of
the countries when you turn your uh res
uh permanent residency into a passport
like Greece right you have to speak
Greek so consider like you know those
requirement as well
um
yeah I think um we'll close out one more
question I think we might have time for
one question maybe two uh
uh fast forward to
2050 2050 the vision for RNs what is um
you know I think about this a lot for
for build I we're it's kind of a
different space um for what we're doing
uh you know it's Economic Development so
it's real estate it's Ventures it's
small business and um um you know we
think about a um10 billion real estate
Equity footprint that's actually shared
between
um between members so if you're a member
in one city there's a third space or
real estate footprint that you actually
hold and you have incentivized Equity
across the entire um kind of global
footprint um but um you know these
things are always kind of refining RNs
is definitely pretty pretty mature
product so uh 2050 we're out about 25
years now what is what is it look like
what does rsid look like and what does
pala look like as a what changes for
uh uh you know um on that same
trajectory yeah so for pal and let me
talk about pal first I think by that
time our goal is to get them 100,000
people so far we got 35,000 so we're
about like 35% already but if we're able
to reach 100,000 people then then our
the number one um it can basically
support a country right it no longer
depends on us right now we uh depend on
the compan
fund from us they you know they just pay
the pal 80 million and in exchange they
you know they they take one of our
Island for for the for the
military and yeah so for po I think this
is a good pretty uh first mover
Advantage right so they kind of like
offer this Residency program first and
then it g to to to uh to attract people
there so I think it's you know for Palo
is is from from that front that's kind
of a pretty uh
advantage and and for uh for RNs you
know like we're definitely thinking
about
expanding um you know other identity
Solutions like kind of the Thailand
driver's license and also because when
you move to a new place right it's
pretty it's not that easy right you need
to get a driver's license you know get
your local Insurance you need to know
where you know which hospital to go you
need to know like you know where to put
your kids into school so what we want
you know for our vision is just to to
make your guys kind of situated in that
in that new uh new new location really
really well right so that's what we want
to to achieve I mean uh actually already
you know we we we hope to do so but in
in in 2050 uh yeah when I'm 60 years old
I I think um this infrastructure would
definitely be already uh already like
running by that by that point so
whenever you move to to to a new place
you know the first thing came to your
mind is probably RNs right that's the
location you go and that's the center
you go for your initial need right we're
probably going to help you for you know
your your your first three month into a
new location then your high
on um I think we may have time for one
or two questions until the host kick me
out but
um we do okay great okay uh one question
yeah um I think there's a microphone
here in the middle if you wanted to
scoot on up
here hey thanks a lot it's a very
interesting um like what what you're
doing is very interesting and cool but I
have a question um how compatible is
your solution with the underlying legal
infrastructure internationally because
there are so many like uh if you go to
ex country they want to screen you
against sanctions or do kyc they need to
actually retain some of your data right
like maybe your gender uh resident say
you they need to keep your copy of your
passport so with your solution you're
decreasing like you're minimizing the
data that is exposed or disclosed but on
the other hand on another jurisdiction
it may not be compatible so they may may
need much more data to let you in so how
your how is your solution compatible
with this existing legal
infrastructure that's actually a very
good question so the uh to just to
repeat that question uh you know like
it's okay you know if you uh use like
palow institution right but if you go to
UAE or Europe what if they require you
know like you to disclose everything
answer is no
solution right if Europe requires you to
disclose that then they require you to
to disclose that right but I think what
you can do is for like say for example
for fi financial institutions right they
say you need to do
kyc but what kind of detailed
requirement in there they didn't specify
right they say you need to you know know
your customer but they didn't say you
cannot Outsource
right once they say that you can
oursource I think that's where we came
into place you know that the you can say
like the the uh the sanctions was
already checked by RNs for example right
and then for like other institution you
just don't need to go and then show your
ID here and there you just do mint once
right and you can check that morco rout
so that RNs as us we cannot even change
your information right we have your
sanction we have your PP
we have your like fraud uh checks so
everything is you know if it's true then
if the B the bank can choose to trust us
to fulfill their kyc obligations but if
you go to like if if they say for
example for hotel for example they say
oh you would have to you know the
country requires but we we're trying to
notch you know this in this direction as
much as as possible for word coin you
know word ID I think is too much you
know they say oh you just use you're you
know you're scan your eyes and then you
can do everything it's that's maybe like
20 years later but for now you know
we're just trying to minimize like as
much as we can and then also we go to a
lot of the this identity weeks identity
um kind of talks with other
jurisdictions to try to minimize the
requirement that they need they actually
they only need to prove you are not a
criminal right why know my age right so
the pursuit of global Mobility Sovereign
Global Mobility um with that I think
we're we're out of time um will how can
we find you where where do we need to go
to check out RNs
ID uh you can go to irs. and then uh
reach out to customer support and tell
them you know your my audience at a
parallel society and then that probably
will help you
yeah uh thank you so much much
[Music]